Jenna: If you're eager to
travel and see the world
beyond the four walls of your home,
I'm right there with you.
So I asked my friend
Caroline, to plan a road trip
that will dare me and all of us
to see the US in a new way.
I'm Jenna Laurenzo and
this is Travel Dares
Season US.
On this season of Travel Dares,
I'm on a mission to find
the most interesting,
unexpected, and unique
destinations America has to offer.
My first stop right here in Williamsburg,
known worldwide for its
historical re-enactments
of American Colonial life.
But my friend Caroline
has planned for me to see
a different side of the city,
and I can't wait to find
out where we're headed.
Let's give her a call.
(phone beeping)
Caroline: Hey, how are you?
Jenna: I'm good. How are you?
Caroline: I'm good.
I'm so excited for you.
What is going through your head?
Jenna: I'm just so excited
to go on a road trip.
Caroline: Yay!
Well, are you ready for your first clue?
Jenna: I'm very ready for my first clue.
Caroline: Okay. So your clue
is: Commander-in-chief or bust?
Jenna: Interesting. That
sounds presidential.
Caroline: It could be. It could not be,
but I'm not going to
give you anything else.
I'm just gonna have you, go for it!
Jenna: Thank you so much, I'm so excited.
Caroline: Awesome, Bye, Have fun.
Jenna: Bye.
(upbeat music playing)
What the heck is that?
Hey!
John: Hello Jenna, How are you?
Jenna: Good. This is incredible.
John: Welcome to the
Ruins of President's Park.
Is this the most unique
place you've ever seen?
Jenna: It's the most
something, I've ever seen.
John: Well come on,
Let me show you around.
(mysterious music playing)
John: So I can tell by
the look on your face
that you've got questions.
May I give you a little background,
as to what you're looking at?
Jenna: Yes.
John: All right. So here is
the history of this place.
There was a sculptor by
the name of David Adickes
who became inspired to
create all of these statutes
after he visited Mount Rushmore.
He and some others created
three sets of these.
This particular set of
sculptures was in a park
about 12 miles from here
called Presidents Park.
And it was functional from
about 2004 until 2010.
And then another company came
in and purchased the property.
The owner of the heads right now,
ended up being commissioned
to come put these in a stone crusher.
Can you imagine being asked to destroy,
42 beautiful sculptures of
the American US Presidents?
Jenna: That would be an interesting ask.
John: That was, so
fortunately for all of us,
he ended up declining and
figuring out a way to salvage them
specifically what he did you can see.
All of them have holes in
the tops of their heads
Jenna: Is that how they
were transported here?
John: That's what he
did is he took chains,
attached them to that rebar on the inside,
hooked it up to the end of his excavator,
rocked them off of their
massive blue foundations,
put them up onto a flatbed.
And then strapped them down one
by one, on a bunch of tires,
and then over the course
of about three weeks
with a crew of six, he saved them.
Now that you've got a
history of this place,
let me walk you around a
little bit, to give you
some individual facts about
some of the presidents.
And there actually might
be a pop quiz at the end.
So pay attention.
Jenna: Should I, be taking notes?
John: That's not a bad idea.
So Jenna,
the question that always
comes up from our guests
is how did the owner decide to
lay them out the way he did?
You'll notice that 39 of the
heads are clustered over there.
And then three of the
heads are separate here.
Everybody understands and appreciates
why George Washington is there,
and where Abe Lincoln is there.
But I got a lot of questions,
as to how did Andrew Jackson
made it front and center.
Jenna: Yeah
John: So I finally went to
the owner and asked him how
Andrew Jackson got the
prime spot on the property.
And he basically told them because,
he has a man crush on him.
He likes the way he looks.
Jenna: I like that answer.
John: That's why he's there.
So his nickname was Old Hickory.
Because he was as tough
as Old Hickory. So yeah.
Jenna: Quite a nickname
John: Yeah
George Washington,
most people don't know
that he was a red head.
Jenna: Wait, Hold on. He was a red head?
John: He was a red head.
That is not a wig. He powdered his hair.
and Abe, how tall do you
think he was? Just guess
Jenna: Statuesque.
Very much so. 6'4". My height.
So he actually was the tallest
of all of our presidents.
So obviously they all
have interesting facts,
associated with them all.
Before we go over and talk
about the 39 heads over there.
I want to bring you
over to Abraham Lincoln
and show you something really interesting,
All right?
Jenna: Cool.
John: All right, come on over.
So everybody always
asks, why Abraham Lincoln
is missing the back of his head?
As that excavator was lifting Abraham
onto the flatbed to have him moved here,
he fell backwards off the flatbed.
Jenna: Oh
John: What are the chances?
What are the chances? So he's the only one
that incurred damage during transport.
Let me show you a couple
other things, walk this way
with me here.
Jenna: Yeah.
So a couple interesting facts here
That is Gerald Ford and
what a lot of people
don't know about him is
that he was a male model.
Teddy Roosevelt. Did you know
that he was fifth cousins with FDR?
Jenna: I did not know that.
John: A lot of people don't.
So speaking of Woodrow
Wilson, he was another
Virginia-born president,
the only president
to ever earn a PhD.
Ronald Reagan, here he is. Remember him?
Jenna: He's missing an eyebrow.
John: He is, he was struck by lightning.
Jenna: What? In real life or the statue?
John: Just the statue.
Jenna: OK well that's good to know.
John: What do you think, cool?
Jenna: I think this is incredible.
John: Good.
Jenna: It was not a bust.
John: Ooo, I love hearing it.
It was a presidential.
Should we say victory?
John: Victory absolutely.
But do you remember
when you first arrived.
I told you there might
be a pop quiz at the end?
Jenna: Ah and there's the bust.
John:Come on out. I'm going to
quiz you on a few. Follow me.
Time to test your presidential knowledge.
You ready for some trivia?
John: Ah yeah, let's do it.
Jenna: All right.
We're gonna start with an easy one.
All right. What color was
George Washington's hair?
Jenna: He's a redhead.
John: Boom. Nice job.
Number two. This is a
little more difficult.
I told you Andrew Jackson's
nickname. Do you remember it?
Jenna: Old Hickory
John: Boom
Jenna: That just sounded like
spice that I wanted to add
to my tea or something.
John: OK.
Two for two. This is
kind of easy. Maybe not.
I told you who the tallest president was.
Do you remember who it was?
Jenna: Lincoln.
John: Abraham Lincoln, 6'4"
Jenna: Yes
John: Three for Three
The smartest president, the
only one to ever get a PhD?
You're looking in the right direction.
Jenna: Is it Roosevelt?
John: Close, close.
Woodrow Wilson.
Jenna: That doesn't feel close.
John: That's OK.
Jenna: Doesn't even seem like it rhymes.
I had such an amazing time
at Presidents Park today,
John, so knowledgeable, so
full of history and facts,
stumped me on a few questions,
but I definitely made my
history teacher proud.
It was an incredible
experience. So unique.
There's nowhere in this world like it.
I had no idea what I was getting into.
Honestly, it's just one of those places
that you have to check out yourself.
And here we go with the
clue for the next episode,
let's see. Use your fingers to handcraft
a piece of pre-Colonial
history. All right. All right.
Well, we're in Colonial Williamsburg.
Now we're going somewhere pre-Colonial.
I have no idea what that
means, but I'm really excited.
You'll just have to tune
into the next episode
to see where we're going next.